you get on there with life tenure and
you know you can say what you want them
hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with reason senior
editor Damon root he's the author of the
new book overruled the long war for
control of the US Supreme Court
Damon thanks for talking to thank you
your book talks a bit about how there's
a kind of libertarian moment happening
in US jurisprudence and your book is
actually in an interesting way an
argument for judicial activism but of a
particular sort lay out your case for us
the libertarian moment that's happening
right now is the product of 30 years of
academic work legal activism lawyers
bringing cases basically arguing that
the that the role of the courts is to
protect individual rights and to
underpin to put a stop to government
overreach in various areas property
rights gun rights look the healthcare
case in 2012 me that was the product of
libertarian legal thinking and what
we've seen is and the idea behind that
was simply that the individual mandate
in Obamacare violated you know it it
snapped a Commerce Clause however a last
thing you want that to be saying that
the government can compel individuals to
do things right that the the
Constitution grants the government
enumerated powers and beyond those
powers the government cannot go and that
the interpretation the Obama
administration was relying on for the
for the health care law for the
individual mandate just exceeded what
had been previously allowed and what the
Commerce Clause could bear in a sense of
with judicial activism the way that we
hear about it it's always a will judge
is legislating from the bench and
typically it's conservatives hurling
that at liberal politicians or liberal
judges what is specifically libertarian
about it and is that a good thing
because we always hear you know look we
elect legislators at the state level we
elect Congress at the national level
they're supposed to make rules and
courts are supposed to interpret them
what I tried to do in the book is showed
that this debate about judicial activism
judicial restraint is it's very old been
going on for you know century and a half
I begin with the 14th amendment 1868
when it's ratified and at the time then
you had these judges who are considered
conservatives they were striking down
progressive and
later New Deal led economic regulations
for exceeding the government's powers
and for violating the talk about can you
talk about you know give an example of
one of the better known cases where in
you know in the 19th century or during
the New Deal early stages of where the
court said hey you know what you can't
you you can't make this you can't
invalidate this kind of economic
activity well so the is one of the most
famous and New Deal cases where Franklin
Roosevelt loses overwhelmingly 9 0 this
was the National Industrial Recovery Act
the NRA and the court said that this
this violated the Commerce Clause
basically this was central planning the
government was trying to create created
these mythical codes of fair competition
where they were setting wages setting
prices telling people what they could
produce big business and big government
we're sort of in cahoots setting setting
these cartels and the Supreme Court
stepped in and said you know you can't
do this and this was this was in some
ways the high-water mark of the first
New Deal where where the New Deal didn't
go beyond that in terms of its its reach
but then just a couple years later at
Supreme Court there's a change of
membership a change of views and we
start to see this restrained approach to
economic regulation and the New Deal
from then on start in 37-38 is is upheld
and this sort of older view the what
would you call the libertarian view goes
out of out of vogue until 30 years ago
you know another way to talk about this
is kind of majoritarianism if you're a
if you believe that there aren't
particular rights that people have that
the government can't abrogate if
majority rules right right and liberals
and conservatives many of them are
actually on that side so somebody like
Robert Bork for instance might say or
would have said you know as long as a
duly elected legislature voted in a
particular law you get pretty much got
to respect the majority even if you
don't like the outcome in his book the
tempting of America he wrote in wide
areas of life majorities are entitled to
rule if they wish simply because their
majorities and he took sort of a page
from justice Oliver Wendell Holmes who
is this Progressive Era judge beloved by
the progressive still beloved by
liberals today and homes in one of his
letters he said about his speaking of
his role as a judge he said you know if
the people want to want to go to hell
it's not my job to stop them you know
it's my job it's my job to let them go
to hell
and and that's II mean you just talk
about majority rule that's saying that
you know that the that the legislative
majority is the will of the people that
has to be respected and if we go
straight to the devil then that's that's
you know the finally I find without now
you know part of the question because
libertarians are interested in things
like federalism or devolving you know
certain powers of authorities to
competing units of government or sub
units of government does you know does a
kind of thorough going libertarian
activism judicial activism so they're
really get rid of the idea of federalism
does it really say ultimately no
jurisdiction can impinge on your
individual rights whether it's you know
a school district or a local
municipality or a county or a state or a
federal government what it says that the
Bill of Rights apply to all levels of
government and so that the states and
the localities can't establish religion
the camp restrict your right to free
speech they can't tell you you have no
right to keep and bear arms from
self-defense so in that sense there is
if it were come with the federal courts
there's a central federal legal
authority that you can appeal to and say
my rights are being violated at this
local level of government so there's so
there's I think you could you could say
that there's some tension with
federalism there but the same time what
federalism really says is that the that
the local government state governments
can do some things the national
government can do others but then what
this approach says this libertarian
legal approach is that they're all bound
by the Constitution they're all bound by
the Bill of Rights as well as the
Fourteenth Amendment which protects
unenumerated rights and enumerated
economic rights and that government at
all levels has to obey those and in a
way I mean the libertarian judicial
thinkers I mean what they're doing is
saying that the economic aspects of the
14th amendment or the implications of
that are as important as kind of the
social or civil liberties oh yeah
absolutely and in fact the one of the
big areas of liberal jurisprudence these
days and has been since the mid 60s and
early 70s is privacy rights and abortion
rights and that legal thinking is can be
traced directly back to these
libertarians of the progressive and New
Deal era and in fact in some of the
cases from the mid 60s where the Supreme
Court first starts recognizing privacy
rights they cite and anchor that
protection in some of the libertarian
cases from the 20s and the 30s so
there's a direct sort of connection
there and basically what you see on the
legal left is what we want the court
to protect these personal rights but
when it comes to economic areas hands
off total deference to lawmakers is
there a clear you know reason why
economic rights and I mean the courts in
general have kind of held them and lower
esteem than other types of rights where
where does that come from that comes
from the New Deal that comes from 1937
1938 when the Supreme Court stopped
protecting those rights stop treating
them seriously the same way that other
rights have been been treated and that
was a long legal battle that went was
going on and that's first half of my
book is really about that that this
decades and decades of progressives
Theodore Roosevelt Franklin Roosevelt
Woodrow Wilson all of these leading
figures and then and then lesser-known
ones just arguing that the courts are
they're intruding on the will of the
people they are usurping Democratic you
know the democratic process and
basically all the arguments we associate
nowadays with conservatives when they're
talking about abortion when they say
well these liberal judges are
legislating from the bench with the
progressives of the early twentieth
century they were saying that about the
conservatives who are striking because
that's when if Baker's and you know
bakers and bakery owners say well we
want to work a lot of hours a week or
that gets invalidated you know a law is
passing you can only work so many hours
and the courts say no these guys can
contract however they want right it was
called liberty the contract was the
legal doctrine that was you know found
to reside within the 14th amendment and
yeah that case the Lochner case New York
had passed this law saying you can't
work more than 60 hours a week in a
bakery and the court said well that's
there's no that's not a legitimate
health regulation there's nothing about
if you work 61 hours a week it doesn't
make bread unhealthy there's no
scientific evidence to show that this is
a health or safety law and if it's not a
legitimate health or safety law then it
violates the 14th amendment talk a
little bit about the you know that who
are the leading lights of the kind of
libertarian legal activism movement and
where did they come from what are the
institutions and you know what are their
kind of intellectual genealogy where
does that come out it begins in the
academy begins with law professors and
historians the late bernard Siegen
Richard Epstein Randy Barnett those are
big important legal thinkers and their
ideas influenced lots of people in terms
of putting these ideas into practice the
Cato Institute has a center for
constitutional studies that's been
hugely important that's really really
kind of the
the center of all of this that's going
on in terms of taking these ideas into
the courtroom the Institute for justice
they're you know they're bringing these
cases bring them to the Supreme Court
Pacific Legal Foundation is doing that
also so you have this this convergence
of you get the ideas you've got this
institutions and you get the lawyers and
activists were push you're going to go
and you know one of the things you hear
about always is that you know the
leading law schools you know the Harvard
jails etc are always very liberal and
you know our groups like the Federalist
Society or places within law schools
that kind of either recognized or
started debates about different
traditions of law that I mean that's
kind of where this all gets started
Federalist Society is huge I mean you
can't talk about the fact that we have a
Supreme Court right now that is
basically right-leaning there's a five
conservative you know majority on it I
mean that is the product of Federalist
Society activism for many years federal
societies formed in the early 80s in law
school campuses and you know the
conservative legal ideas at that point
we're really just out in the wilderness
and libertarian ideas even more so the
wilderness within the you know the
wilderness and Federalist Society grows
an influence and liberals conservatives
libertarians all these people
participate in federal society events
and these ideas get batted around
conservative ideas you know take hold
and then libertarians start to really
influence the conservative movement in a
number of areas and that's I think
really the fruit we're seeing you know
right now talk you know you mentioned
the Supreme Court we've got you know
what's the average age on the Supreme
Court is like 600 years old right what
is likely to happen over the next couple
of years and how much does it matter who
gets to pick Supreme Court justices
because you know this is this is one of
the you know recurring themes of
American politics particularly
presidential elections that you know
you're not just fighting for president
you're voting for the Supreme Court well
I mean it's it's it is a huge deal who
you know who puts justices on because
they're gonna serve for many decades and
can have a huge impact depending on the
case I think we're see several
retirements in the next few years I
think you know Ginsburg is likely to
step down at some point
Scalia Kennedy Breyer they're not far
behind and depending on you know if if a
Scalia is replaced by a Democratic
president that could be a big deal if
ginza burgers were placed by Republican
that's a big deal and that could change
the balance on on
on any number of issues you know there's
a belief that at least since Robert Bork
I'm in searing back in the 80s that you
have to be kind of a nonentity and not
really have like a track record or a
written record that can be dredged up
and actually gone through is that
legitimate to say about Supreme Court
nominees or I mean are we getting you
know our presidents afraid to nominate
people who have actually written a lot
and done a lot they I think they are
afraid to do that if you look at Elena
Kagan she was just had a had a very
distinguished career in government
service but there was basically no paper
trail that could be so you know well I
was still I was the lawyer for the
federal government I was a Solicitor
General I'm not doesn't necessary my
views those are the views administration
I'm just defending them as a good lawyer
in court I mean there was really nothing
not like Bork there's just this you know
this huge paper trail to mine and he's
team you know he weighs in on everything
and that's a shame because you know we
want these innovative legal minds to be
in the running and instead you've got
these very very strategic people who
want to be in the Supreme Court or like
they're laying low keeping their views
to themselves they clearly have views
they're just not sharing them and by the
same token though there's like no
predicting who emerges right I mean like
past performances no indication of
future success on the Supreme Court
right and I guess was eisenhower
famously said that Earl Warren what do
we who we put on the Supreme Court was
his biggest failure well you know David
Souter is the one that the Republicans
point to you know in the recent years
where he's put on and they're expecting
he's going to be a solid vote you know
against roe v wade and he ends up being
basically becoming very liberal on the
bench so yeah there's there's no real
predicting I mean some of them are more
you know so maybe safe bets than others
but you know you get on there with life
tenure and you know you can say what you
want then let's talk a little bit about
issues that are either the court has
just decided or is likely to in the next
term you know that are hot and like how
does how does your kind of understanding
of judicial activism or libertarian
activism on the court play out in things
like the gay marriage debate
well libertarians have been right at the
center of gay rights and gay marriage on
the legal front you know really for the
last several decades the Cato Institute
filed a very important friend of the
court brief in Lawrence vs Texas which
was the case that struck down this the
sodomy ban this banned
on gay behavior in Texas and
libertarians have been pushing for gay
rights ever since and Justice Kennedy
who basically is the swing vote on this
issue who's fairly you could call them
fairly libertarian on gay rights not on
everything he's susceptible to the to
the libertarian legal arguments and he
he cited the Cato brief and his opinion
in Lawrence so I think that that those
ideas are gonna have a big impact on
when the court finally finally tells and
I mean the the court recently chose not
to engage in a bunch of lower level
courts that upheld gay marriage right
right so but though you're you're you
believe that when the court when a lower
court strikes down gay marriage that's
when the Supreme Court will they're
they're waiting for what they call
circuit split where you have one Federal
Circuit says it states you know it's
unconstitutional for them to ban gay
marriage and then another one says no
it's perfectly constitutional this is
its traditional law making this is
morals legislation states have always
done this and and and and once that
happens which I which there's a good
chance it will that be the split and the
Supreme Court will probably take it up
though you know executive power has been
you know what at the forefront of a lot
of people's minds and anxieties in the
entire 21st century what's likely to be
happening with that as far as the
Supreme Court well you know there's
there was several big executive power
cases last term where the Obama
administration lost you know basically
you know nine zip on a bunch of key
issues recess appointments the treaty
power and you know what we're looking at
in the future is you know the NSA spying
at some point that that kind of that
kind of intrusive government overreach
that that originates with the executive
branch or executive agencies and that's
that's an instance where you know
libertarians are again going to be
pushing for for limits on the federal
government they they they're
conservative a lays on the Supreme Court
may depart from them on that
yeah well talk a little bit about that
because I mean basically you know I mean
the libertarian argument would be that
the state doesn't have this kind of
overly broad or you know unlimited
ability to to surveil people even if
even if Congress goes along with and
it's not fully clear that they have but
conservatives then who oftentimes you
know will fall in line with libertarians
on certain issues in in matters like
this there's kind of a
right right I mean I've seen in in the
the Obama years conservatives much more
open to the idea that well maybe the
president doesn't have these really
broad unwritten unilateral powers which
was a doctrine that was quite popular
during the Bush years because
conservatives are worried about you know
Obama suddenly having these brothers
the justices on the Supreme Court are a
little more insulated from that sort of
partisan back-and-forth although you
know they may they may also you know
look at who's in the White House and and
that may color their judgment as well
but that's you know that's an issue
where executive power and police powers
more generally law enforcement we want
to call it that that's something where
you know libertarians are at odds with
conservatives in many cases on those
issues what about the Second Amendment I
mean this is you know for decades I mean
there was a real revolution in kind of
expanding gun gun ownership laws at the
state level and now more recently at the
federal level in a way that you know if
you were talking 50 years ago I don't
think anybody would have predicted that
the Supreme Court would be really
upholding an individual right to you
know kind of own and bear right onnum
bear arms in a very broad way is our
Second Amendment rights likely to be
peeled back anytime soon I don't think
the Supreme Court can be peeling them
back I mean there's a question if the
courts gonna take another Second
Amendment case any time soon there been
a number of promising ones and what the
court has said is there's it's an
individual right you've got it within
the home for self defense purposes those
are the facts of one of the cases and
then that applies to the states they're
through the follow up case mcdonald for
chicago but now there's a question of
well does the second amendment play
outside the home can you care can you
can you carry if you bear the arms in
public and under what circumstances and
what sort of restrictions are allowable
and what or not and eventually the court
has to has to hear that kind of case
because that's something where you
basically the circuits are split on that
issue is it you know is it clear which
way I mean I can understand where the
you know where the libertarian argument
comes down is there a sense of where the
the court would go with a case like that
it's the logic of Heller and McDonald
the two Second Amendment cases that
we've had in the last few years would
suggest that there's some right to bear
arms outside of the home and there may
be subject to reasonable restrictions
but it can't be totally banned and the
bans can't be arbitrary and capricious
like they are and frankly in some places
but beyond that it's it
not clear Scalia interestingly has said
has made some comments that could be
read a few ways one of which is just
like well you know we you know we
haven't heard the case yet will decided
when we decided and another has
suggested that maybe he thinks that well
you know the bear the carrying part of
it is it's not so clear-cut but that's
that's something that you know we're
gonna have to wait and see second
amendment groups are pushing for those
cases libertarian lawyers who've been at
the truly at the front of this from the
beginning Alan Gura I mean who is
basically one these two cases working
with people at Cato Institute Institute
for justice Clark Neely Bob Leavy I mean
these guys are libertarian lawyers and
they they won these cases and they're
pushing for more what about you know
kind of cases about what happens when
state law and federal law is in conflict
most obviously in marijuana cases and
you know the race decision from a few
years ago in a couple of other cases
where you have states saying okay you
know what we're gonna allow medical
marijuana in the case of Colorado and
Washington you know we're we're fully
legalizing marijuana for production and
consumption that's at odds with the
federal law and obviously the Obama
administration has backed off kind of
hard enforcement of that is that going
to come to a head in the Supreme Court
where we will actually learn you know
what is what is the algorithm to say you
know at federal law trumps state laws in
certain cases but not in others is that
likely to come up I'd like to see
another case like I don't think we will
I think the Supreme Court unless the
membership changes dramatically I mean
Scalia will cast an important vote on
behalf of the federal government which
was exercising what it thought was
Commerce Clause powers so one of the
issues in the Obamacare case and that
was an important precedent for the
federal government in that case I think
that the court basically says you right
now their view is that this issue was
settled in the New Deal
the federal government has these broad
powers and they and they trumped the
states when the federal when the
Commerce Clause is invoked and you know
that you pot smokers you know can just
go home and cry about it right there
until you elect a federal government
that changes exactly speaking of
Obamacare there's still a couple of
lingering legal challenges is that
likely to come up again and if so is
there any reason to believe that the
Supreme Court will actually get around
to saying oh yeah by the way Obamacare
is unconstitutional and therefore for
votes on the court right now to that say
Obamacare was unconstitutional in its
entirety the four dissenters
and takes four votes for the court to
hear a case so I think that there's
there is a chance that one of these
these these tax cases could could reach
a Supreme Court and this has to do with
the who collects the the tax payments or
the you know or the subsidies for
various kinds of Obamacare premium right
the law itself is written in such a way
that it seems to say that you can you
can qualify for these tax subsidies if
you get it through a health exchange
established by a state now the federal
government is established exchanges that
are covering many other states and so if
you get it through one of these do you
qualify for the tax subsidies and if and
if you don't then Obamacare kind of
falls apart because it loses this
funding mechanism there's a few cases
before the federal circuit's right now
that I mean this I think that by the
time that kind of issue reaches a
Supreme Court there's a strong textual
argument that that the law says this one
thing and that's you you know you have
to read it you have to read the law the
way it says and I think there's votes
for that I die I think that John Roberts
had a chance to overturn Obamacare in
2012 and he's probably gonna be less
likely to do it in 2015 2016 but you
know you never know as a final question
talk a little bit your work at reason I
mean you've been writing for reason for
over a decade you you've been on staff
since 2008 and you've always had a
strong interesting kind of legal writing
in history where does that come from big
history nerd growing up in college where
things I like about writing about the
Supreme Court and about the law is that
you know these are all ghost stories in
a way I mean they there's all of these
things from the past that come haunt us
in the present and you need to know all
that and it's I like digging around and
you know in the old sources so it's just
had a lifelong interest in history yes
all right well we'll leave it there
Damon root thank you so much he is the
author of the new book overruled the
long war for control of the US Supreme
Court Damon thank so much thank you Nick
for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie